[Music]  foreign  [Music]  I think that the dream final for me it's  France versus Ghana my prediction to win  the World Cup is Brazil I'm going to go  for the fairy tale ended for Lionel  Messi to emulate maradona's performance  in 1986. my pick for the World Cup has  to be  England I think Brazil will win the  world cup and if there's an outside  chance maybe England I'm cheering for a  Team USA in football World Cup my  favorite player is Messi and I really  hope that he can win this year because  it's his last World Cup and I want  Argentina to win my prediction for the  winner of the World Cup will be Brazil I  will be rooting for Brazil for the World  Cup and my prediction who's gonna win  the World Cup I think Brazil obviously  pump for this year's World Cup and  guitar here's my prediction it's gonna  be shocking USA Baby  [Applause]